[Music]
can you please uh set up our guest uh
yes we uh are being joined now by um
well you just recently ran for congress
uh he is we just actually played a
really great clip m recently he's the
guy that we need to although i mean the
moment we saw sienna and do a hip piece
on him we're like who is this gentleman
who's this guy
so anthony sabatini joining us live hey
what's up man how you doing
good to see you guys yeah it's uh still
serving in the florida house ran for
congress
kevin mccarthy who's a horrible cuck
dropped 1.5 million against me two weeks
ago so
that was uh to be expected and then we
lost the race last night but
we got big plans for next year and i'm
still finishing my state house term
uh i'll be done in the state house in
about two and a half months so hopefully
hopefully we get some interesting things
happening before i finish that up yeah
but you know remember what liz cheney
said you know who else lost an election
abraham lincoln so i mean you're you're
in great company and she's just like him
so yeah she's exactly like him in that
she wants to continuously expand federal
powers and crush the states
she has no shame no she really doesn't
and honestly she really should right
well i mean once your dick cheney's dog
when you're dick cheney's daughter right
it's hard to grow up with any shame yeah
right it's like damn my dad might maybe
my dad was a war criminal who knows who
knows yeah
but man no i you know it's it it
what do you you know what
what are you gonna do man [ __ ] [ __ ]
happens and honestly here's the truth
the truth of the matter is
when you have cnn doing a hit piece on
you that only means that you're doing
something like i always look at it that
way whenever cnn's like
that's where we're like wait so this
guy's saying what abolish the fbi we've
been saying that too yeah and it's like
they they they act like it's a radical
position the people that just said
defund the police are saying it's a
radical position
yeah of course a lot of the most common
sense stuff we have to do the most
obvious stuff
seems radical and the reason it seems
radical is because our elected class of
republican leaders are generally cowards
and they're afraid to talk about it and
so because they're so cowardly it it
makes the position seem more radical so
it's this big contradiction it's okay
here's what needs to happen here's the
best thing to happen
but because our elected class won't talk
about it you know it becomes more rare
you hear about it more rarely
it seems more radical even though it's
not radical it's just obvious and
something that need that we need to do
so and and it's and it's it's right in
two different ways so like one it's
right in the immediate moment in the
sense that we have this horrible threat
of this ever-expanding unaccountable
federal so-called law enforcement agency
that's now like haunting us
whether it be j6 now the former
president of the united states various
ways but also like just the old school
conservative argument of why did we have
a giant federal law enforcement why not
have state attorneys general have
compacts together where they stop
interstate crimes so
it's just it's so obvious on so many
levels that this is what we should be
doing yet how many republicans do we
have talking about it right they had to
come find a state representative in
florida to interview because other than
marjorie there's only a few republicans
even talking about it in the elected
ranks
so that's why they came and found me
it's just sad that we don't have
republicans who aren't willing to say
what's obvious well but
you know i wanted um they they call me
silver linings merch here so
on the bright side at least we have at
least we have brave republican leaders
out there fighting the good fight like
lindsey graham and dan crenshaw and i
think that they're really just out there
just doing like doing god's work like
ordering people to shoot protesters
outside or you know uh saying on
national television that we should
assassinate uh the democratically
elected leader of a nuclear superpower
you know just run-of-the-mill stuff but
but you're the but it's funny you hear
all that but you're the radical one yeah
you know what i mean no we need to
assassinate putin and you're like i just
think maybe we should scale back all
these illegal investigations and they're
like whoa crazy man
relax
exactly yeah lindsey graham can say
whatever he wants because uh you know as
long as he
he uh is playing into the prejudices of
the oldest part of our electorate who
doesn't really understand what time it
is
uh
it it's okay no matter how insane i
can't even tell you how many people i've
talked to who are like
you know we need to go to war
during the campaign we need to go war
with russia you know we got to push back
on russia we need to bomb the hell out
of them and invade you know go into
ukraine tomorrow like this
this part of the republican party does
exist and it's totally insane and uh
radical but
somewhat popular i guess i don't know it
plays into the prejudices of this this
anti-communist anti-anti-sovereign i
should say
mentality that still exists right they
still think it's like the 80s the right
the red scare they think it's a red
scare i mean they still do so it's
considered normal even though what
they're saying is totally insane and
radical
it's normal in the sense that there's
like a weird consensus for it i don't
know well i mean i think the problem is
is that what we're finding out is at
least this is what we always say on the
show is that a lot of these republicans
you know democrats are doing something
not even borderline in my opinion you're
doing some just straight up illegal
things right like just absolutely doing
that and and and whenever republicans
get power at least it seems seem like at
least since since 9 11 2001 whenever
republicans get power they don't do
anything like there's no teeth there's
some don't get me wrong there are some
that are out there that are fighting and
screaming and and you know [ __ ] rand
paul's yelling at fauci at least
someone's saying something you got holly
yeah you got that that old dude kennedy
who i love oh kennedy is hilarious but
but my point is is like
i don't want another mitch mcconnell i i
so the point is even if there's this
huge red wave that they say is going to
come
i think every real every person who's
ever seen this party is is going like
but if there's more crenshaws at
mcconnell's like
what are we doing that they want to give
more money to ukraine too
yeah well the future of the country is
the soul you know the battle for the
soul of the country still the civil war
republican party it's the primary the
republican party
and you know third 20 20 25 percent of
people show up for but that is literally
the election that determines where the
whole country goes
um you know that the direction the
republican party the resistance right
the the group of people who want to
actually try to put the country in a
different direction than where it's been
going for 50 years that's why it's so
important and that's why this you know
that's where our attention needs to be
is getting good guys elected and you
know you look at guys like lindsey
graham mitch mcconnell
um a majority of the senate but even
probably half the house mccarthy type
guys
you know it's sad that they're not being
primary more often and we replace them
with more maggot candidates who actually
understand like what we need to be doing
right now in the country
and that's my whole purpose that's my
whole focus is getting people spirited
engaged in these republican primaries at
every level of government so we can get
stronger fighters in if we
go to the november election with a
loser
empty suit establishing republican
then you know it doesn't matter if he
wins or not because he's just going to
cave on everything it's just we'll lose
more slowly but we'll still lose we got
to get people who are actually going to
fight hard and push an offensive uh
push offense when it comes to policy
well i think republicans keep thinking
if you play really really really good
defense
that's they mix it up for offense it's
just not yeah defense is great but it
doesn't get anything done and that and
that's the problem it's like
it's it's like it's like covering up a
paper cut when the when the entire thing
has cancer it's like i mean that takes
care of the paper cut but there's a
bigger problem going on and i think the
bigger issue is is that i think now
we're seeing a breaking point i think
we're seeing the new republican party is
little by little breaking out of the
shell from the old
patriot act neocon you know
put a boot in your ass kind of you know
stuff and there's kind of more turning
into like no this isn't about having an
american flag in your car and eating
anything like that this is about a
fundamental destruction of a country and
it's being done right in your eyes and
then when we're when we go okay
republicans are in charge what are you
gonna do a lot of times you're like well
you know how they said they were gonna
pass a 8 trillion dollar spending bill
we got it down to 7.6 i'm like okay that
sucks though
yeah it's it does feel like at times the
country i grew up in
is just being dismantled and like just
sold for parts you know what i mean it's
like when you just it's like a junkyard
getting a totaled car and you're just
watching them pull all the catalytic
converter out you know what i mean
you're going no it's not going to be a
car anymore i guess we're just going to
sell just a bunch of metal but i mean
these dudes that are in charge
especially the establishment republicans
what gets me about them is they would
rather hold on to their jobs
than win
like they'd rather hold on to their jobs
than than make america a better place
they they don't want to concede their
position that always happens and that
dictates all their whatever the policy
is no matter what action and government
is the thing that dictates it is
you know congress at some point if it
wants to stop the bad things that are
happening
basically has to stop spending as much
on whatever the bad thing is and then
that threatens a government shutdown and
because we have cowards in the
republican on republican office who
under no circumstance would ever get
caught in the scenario of having to shut
the government down because they think
they'll lose november they therefore
will do nothing in the meantime it's the
opposite of what the democrats do right
because they they'll just continue to
fund tyranny all day long knowing the
republicans will actually vote for it
but but the at the heart of it so the
democrats know
that they're always going to lose power
like the next cycle but they just need
to run the ball down the fields as fast
as they possibly can while they still
have power lose power and then get back
and run the ball down the field again
they don't mind losing political power
because they know when the republicans
get the ball they'll just hold on to it
and play defense the entire time
so it's just a cycle like right now
kevin mccarthy when he takes over
speaker god forbid he wins
you know he's going to push a really
safe defensive compromised agenda hoping
that that makes the republicans look
more appealing going into 24
instead of actually just using the power
that he has
to hell with it just deliver on some
policy victories and use the power when
you have it but this is like auto repeat
for like 50 years like compromise when
we have power hoping that we get uh
hoping that we get awarded the next
cycle and never works out that way 28
2016 the 2018 we played defense the
whole time against the democrats even
though we had all three branches of
government they still took over anyway
so we just need leaders who have courage
and understand this like repeating
phenomenon within the republican party
and uh mccarthy's just not that guy well
i mean i i agree with you and i also
believe the other side the other thing
of that is is like a great example of
that is
when when when when they when the
republicans have the house and they have
the senate and it's like okay we're
going to build the wall right we're
building the wall right we're like and i
remember man i remember
mitch mcconnell being like oh donald
trump doesn't know how slowly it works
up here unless it's 18 billion for
ukraine then all of a sudden that stuff
gets fast tracked right through
and then how much was our wall supposed
to cost that we couldn't afford eight it
was like three or four billion and they
were like we can't come up with that
kind of money
you know what i mean and then like biden
gets in and he's like oh she's gonna
print a couple trill huh a couple
trillion and you're like wait with a t
six or seven billion is the number
somebody threw out recently when they
were
uh comparing the two that was i think my
my favorite excuse my money was out that
day in fact actually if you think about
it and this is some somebody told me
this i think it's true rand paul tried
to slow the whole thing down to say okay
i know you guys are gonna pass this
anyways but let's include a provision
that allows us to at least track the
money get the inspector general attract
the money and they're adamantly opposed
to it
one of the reasons why they're adamantly
opposed to it was
some
folks who've watched this space already
thought that they basically had already
sent the money that they had already
made commitments to send the money and
that making the congress wait another
week
there would have been a legal technical
serious issue there because the money
was already being sent that's how fast
the money was
that they couldn't even deliberate on
the bill any longer because they needed
to get these so-called arms and aid in
the hands of the oak crate ukrainian
oligarch so yeah that's that's what was
going on
it's so funny seeing that too because
it's um it's it's not even how quickly
but it's funny how the left-wing media
like you know somebody proposed the bill
that you know they that that uh that the
congress should have five days to read a
bill which seems fair when it's 6 000
pages or whatever and then they're like
can you believe they want to have five
days to read a bill i'm like yeah that
be really nice if they read every page
of something that's going to be law uh
forever but if there's one thing i've
learned from the patriot act is that you
don't have to read every little bill
that comes through sometimes you have
lunch you know you have lunch
appointments and you know dates you got
to go on okay but that's that's the cup
here's the one good thing and this is
the best thing that i'll say why do you
think out of all the 50 states
especially during covet
florida was so sheltered and stayed
america as close as you could be america
compared to the other 40 united states
we live here we're in orlando
well uh you know i think it all has to
do with descendants the cat the
legislature is no different from any
state legislature you got a couple of
the freedom fighters like me
who are more mega or hard right like
actually understand the stakes of what's
at stake you got some rhinos on the
other side who are just horrible liberal
and almost democrats right pushing all
types of liberal policies and stuff then
you just got like a big fat happy middle
that is just gonna do what they're told
basically like cattle
and
what we what made us different was we
had a member former member of the
freedom caucus a very principled
you know freedom-believing uh
congressman who happened to win the
governorship here mostly because donald
trump endorsed him that's why he won
and that of course that's ron desantis
and he shaped
the whole reshaped all the state's
policies and uh
done things that had his primary
opponent adam putnam won
we'd be a totally different state right
now we wouldn't have had any of the
um
strong anti-fouchy
anti-coveteering response that we ended
up with it's all just kissing desantis
that's it now i was using my pulpit and
doing what i could to push the governor
and to like you know back the governor
up to continue to be
even more pro-offense on on the
coveteering and all these different
issues whether it be the transgender
agenda the crt all of it
that's what i've tried to use my office
work but the truth is it didn't really
matter because he kind of drew the
policy and the legislature was just
along for the ride
and so yeah got to give him all the
credit pretty much but i i i do think
that that there is a change we're just
talking about it we're we're friends
actually with alex stein and it's
actually this a lot of you dropped that
name i i'm sorry do you know jay moore
told me you know you know let me tell
you something right now i'm going to
tell you something right now this is
important
never name drop j moore told me that
yeah i know that's okay um anyway
anyway uh no the reason i was bringing
that up is because um there is there is
this this thing where things that used
to be like you know you said you know
like far right and these it's becoming
mainstream now right i mean objectively
speaking via these ideas
are it's people over here are funnier
they're getting more stuff done they're
smarter you know when you have bill
maher having to apologize now we're at
the point of this we're at the orwellian
point of the book where bill maher is
apologizing for not being leftist enough
that's where we are now
and and it's and it's super weird
because i think the days of the old
liberal are gone right oh yeah they're
done i mean the old conservatives dead
too though really yeah i mean what are
they conserving so i mean it's the same
thing on both sides yeah everybody's
like i don't know just gotta cut your
kid's dick off i guess it's everybody's
like i guess and then everybody's fine
and everybody's fine
did you saw the gays against groomers
just got kicked off for the third time
on twitter like why you can't beat you
can't be against grooming like it is it
is unbelievable and i will say the the
one lesson that i think people should
learn from desantis is don't back down
don't ever back down i do find it odd
though like do you find it odd that like
when you see how
they just
completely
misrepresent everything like they've
changed the meanings but like we've
literally changed the definition of like
a dozen words in the past few years just
to cover up for literal crimes and now
it's like
everything takes on this weird
opposite uh meaning of the original
meaning of the word and and it's like up
is down i love that they call desantis
like this
tyrannical dictator fascist and i'm like
he dismantled disney's like private
imperial districts
he
let people go to work and open up their
beauty salons when other states were
like no buy everything from amazon and
you're just going to have to eat you
know bugs and beans and stuff that's
just life now and you know all this
stuff like pretty much open kept the
beaches open got business coming into
florida all this stuff and they're like
he is a fascist dictator and i'm like
ron desantis has not gotten in my way
of doing anything i want to do all the
time he's been governor anything i feel
like doing not at one point in my life
as ron desantis been like huh hold the
brakes but why it's like why why is this
happening or why how could this possibly
happen that they can just totally change
the definition of words and then the
sort of cattle random people who don't
understand what's happening or just
nodding their heads and going along for
the ride
it's the it's the complete and total
disinterest republicans have had in real
education
for k-12 i mean they almost never talked
about education in a real way sometimes
you hear republicans gesture about well
we're going to do a civics exam in the
12th grade it'll be the american
citizenship exam and that's our civics
initiative it's like
we have totally downplayed critical
thinking and civics like k through 12
like we need to like
drastically increase the amount of
funding
and hour like necessary hours for like
students to have for like critical
thinking courses language and like
government and civics because the people
that are going out into the world and
then voting
are not equipped to understand like
what's happening like they do not
realize
that the media is basically just fooling
them into thinking
uh that you know ron desantis is entire
whatever else we just don't we don't
educate people to the degree in which we
need to when it comes to civics and just
general critical thinking that's
something we really need to get serious
about like now like right now like we
need to go to in my opinion either 100
school choice and get them out of the
indoctrination factories but at the
exact same time working on like really
really working at better civics and
history and critical thinking uh
curriculum because it's it's not working
i mean men i gotta tell you like you go
talk to the average person coming out of
public schools and they're just not
they don't get it they're barely voting
and uh
we just really really at the state level
so much of what needs to happen to stuff
at the state level like i ran for
congress because
if i didn't run there was
what happened that was what i was most
fearful of which is like a total rhino
would just win and then go up there
being that the suit and get and just not
fight
for a strong republican party instead
they would just kind of be a backbencher
and just sit there and pair whatever
kevin mccarthy says but put it but
enough of rick scott sorry i had to i i
had to i'm sorry go ahead no but i mean
but i i have to say this really a lot of
the best things that need to happen to
save the country are things that happen
at state level like i ran for congress
for that but really if you told me what
are the top i'm kind of a hypocrite
because if you said one of the top five
things need to happen like right now to
save the country they're mostly state
level things like the cnn interview had
to do with what the state of florida
could do to fight back against doj which
is severing ties communication task
forces enter
local funding agreements with doj and
fbi et cetera and the education space
the feds almost have nothing to
education yeah there's a federal
department of education yeah we need to
shut it down but 99 of the funding of
education is coming from the state
already and why are we allowing the left
to like dictate it why aren't we making
it like really based why are we making
it really conservative education why are
we not
making better citizens we're just
fat lazy there's just too many fat lazy
grifters in the republican party who do
not take the power that they're given
seriously not ex exercising in the right
way we need to like have like
conservative education that we're just
not doing it that that's that's a really
good strategy no but that's it's by
design i mean to be honest with you
everybody that's in power is basically
just like fat [ __ ] person that wants
us to they want us all to be fat they
also want us to be stupid and they want
us to be unarmed like those are the
three
like pillars of what our government
wants they want us fat stupid and
unarmed and and probably on a various
cocktails of ssris of drugs also and and
estrogen-based foods to just keep us you
know chilling hanging out smoking weed
all day
that's what they want but they do and
and it's it's it's funny because you
know you're 100 right about
another question why do democrats they
why do they win they control the
education system they those kids are
being dropped indoctrinated from day one
all the way through college and then
they go to college they drop out and now
we're saying it's okay that you didn't
get a real job we're gonna forgive your
loans now too big guy but the people
that busted their ass to get a a hvac
degree
or a tech degree screw them though they
don't get their money back no you know
people that want to go liberal dance art
studios degrees are getting their money
back and then hi people right there's
people
look at the numbers a lot of people that
are making the most money right now are
only high school graduates and that's a
real thing if you get the right job
there's some plumbers out there making
more money than some
big people right if you know what you're
doing and you're smart and none of them
get they didn't get a break the problem
is if you you and now you're
incentivizing stupidity right so now
we're going like not only are you going
to indoctrinate you but guess what it's
on the house so we are paying for our
own downfall we're paying our taxes to
do that and why they never fight back
they never fight back and this is why
and they learned it and they used it and
it's conservatives fault the last thing
a conservative wants to be called is
either racist or homophobic even if
you're none of those things
they run from that word and they don't
and and again that's why china's beating
us because you tell china you know what
you're doing is racist to be like yeah
we know we don't care though we do
whatever we want here and that's what's
happening here there's no fighting back
that you know and i agree with i agree
with school choices and i even agree
with homeschooling and stuff like that
but if you don't fundamentally fix what
kids are being taught if kids are being
taught to say their pronouns and not why
george washington was awesome we have a
problem and that's the problem too these
kindergarten teachers are like
shoehorning
conversations about like that's the
whole that was the whole part of like
the parental rights and education act
was something called like because
what about all my children that are
asking me about my my gay butt sex
lifestyle and i'm like i'm pretty sure
those kindergarteners are not asking you
about butt sex you're weird they steer
the conversation in a certain way like
yeah my partner lips have tick tock
exposed a lot of that non-binary partner
it's like that episode of the simpsons
where they're trying to mr samson and
they're stepping on his foot and he's
like i think he's talking to you like
the kids aren't getting it and then
they're like do you see that the lips
are tick-tock some of them are like i am
so frustrated with these these these
kindergartners they're like nazis and
you're like no they just don't care
about butt sacks they just show them
colors and letters and teach them
cursive this should be easy when you're
a kindergarten teacher they're not even
really learning much just give the kid a
juice box halfway through the day let
him run around and tire himself out
before he goes back to his parents and
give him books some puzzles and teach
him socialization that's all you have to
it's the easiest gig and they're like so
anyway i went paddle boarding with my
gay boyfriend this weekend and when we
were oiling each other up listen hey put
your pencil down i'm talking about my
gay trip to fire island you're like so
somebody had to step up and go hey look
let's go back to juice boxes and
workbooks let's just let's go about
juice boxes and workbooks all right
let's keep it simple
well one thing i want to bring up about
this in my response that is this is
we're talking about earlier the
difference between offense and defense
so much of like the winning issue right
now in the public party they think is
like it has saved the country
it's still completely and totally rooted
in defense and what it is is it's like
we're gonna keep critical race theory uh
and transgender lessons out of the
public schools like parental rights if
you can't jam this down the
the uh the mind of a third grader we're
gonna stop that from happening
i get that we're to do that i mean
obviously we should do that we did it
here in florida i was very happy about
it right we did it for at least half the
students that bill should went to the
12th grade stopped in third grade but
whatever agree with that um
that's still defense that's still
defense like that that doesn't get us in
a better position we were we're already
creating libtards
constantly who don't love the country
and uh are gonna go to the insane
diploma mill fake university factories
and and be taught to hate the country
and continue to vote for a tyrannical
party that wants us to be a globalist
lame nation like so we need to go past
the defense and actually like embrace
and it's impossible to get conservatives
to do this but we have to do it or
conserve leaders that is
so-called conservatives we have to get
them to like actually believe in
education system that believe in
affirmative ideals like not just we're
going to stop the crt
but you have to get them to like
actually teach
uh what we think is right and good like
in the schools like actually embrace
what's right and good which is
patriotism and honor like there's a
contra you know there was a controversy
many years ago in the county i live in
lake county
as you guys are from orlando claremont
brewing company baby whoop whoop
stay health district by the way that's
the right i mean i'm right outside i'm
not trying to knock clara the fine city
of claremonts in orlando but i'm a tampa
guy just no hey you leave i'm over here
i'm actually i'm just just south of
where your district ends actually
but in the but this is how far we've
gone in the wrong direction so like in
the 90s there was a school board
takeover or some liberal thing was
pushed and they took over the school
where conservatives took over the school
board in the mid 90s
and this was in the mid 90s is how far
we've gone
there was a school board member that
pushed to make it as part of the
official curriculum
that
it would be taught in lake county public
schools that western civilization
was
the greatest civilization and that it
was in superior to other civilizations
and in the 90s that was considered like
wildly controversial and uh
either failed on a vote or they passed
it i'm pretty sure they passed it and
then a bunch of school board members
were thrown out there was teacher unions
and democrats still had very much
influence in some of the more rural
uh ex-bourbon areas back there and they
were thrown out and that was like a
wildly controversial like how far we've
moved in the wrong direction since then
uh is really uh
immeasurable i think like like right now
if we're not willing to think that the
civilization that has created all the
world's greatest prosperity western
civilization civilization shouldn't be
taught as a fact that western
civilization is the greatest
civilization in the world and that
america is the greatest country in the
world
then we're doing a horrible job in our
public education system so we can sit
here and like
cope cope out and you know have the
copium and believe that like stopping
the crt and transgenderism is like
making us win again but if we don't
affirmatively affirmatively believe and
start promoting real ideals and teach
young people to like love the country
and be great citizens we're still losing
we're still losing we're just losing
very soon we're just pat we're just
patching a leak and not fixing the
problem no i mean that's it band-aid
band-aid band-aid and so like trying to
get the republicans to think differently
about this and realize like losing
really slow it does not equate winning
is probably the thing i'm most focused
on the campaign trail and an office like
just we need stronger leaders
who actually are gonna are gonna use the
education system or anything in their
power that they can affect and change
to make better citizens who are
conservative like make conservative
young people
like use force to do it and they're not
willing to do it
i i mean yeah and but i would really
hope that we're getting there right i
mean i would like we're taking steps in
the right direction i mean to say that
this also is
pushing for like the financial literacy
that was one of my that's one of the
things i mean i know that's still not
like you know hand over the heart and
stand for the flag but it's still a step
you know any level of like literacy
well one more thing about this idea of
like creating affirmative better
values based education is going to
create more conservative citizens at a
young age
i would tell you that and might sound
like a hypocrite here or like i'm
undermining myself i don't think that
we're ever going to have the political
power or will at least not in the near
future to get it done within the public
education system so that's why i
actually do advocate although there's
flaws with it some flaws with it because
you don't have the control
um a 100 school choice system like
arizona did
you know to show you how kind of sort of
how fat and lazy the state legislature
is like over the last six years we went
from being the school choice leader to
now being surpassed by arizona because
arizona has gone further and they went
to a thousand you know 100 percent
universal school choice so any parent
just gets like a 7 500
voucher and as long as it's more like a
coupon but basically you can put your
kid in any private education i think
this is the better way to go because
you're going to get you're going to find
that teachers are more willing or
parents are more willing to want to put
their young person in a values-based you
know pro-citizenship
broke patriotic
christian education more than you ever
would uh be able to get kids in a you
know thinking that way if you embrace
just still public model of education so
we need to go to the arizona based uh
arizona model of 100
private education because you're going
to get more kids in religious and
values-based education that way so that
needs to happen like now like if i was
governor of florida i would call an
emergency special session right now and
pass that bill and do not let any kids
go back into uh
you know these liberal
factories that we call k-12 education
spring like get them all
these coupons and let these new models
of private education that's values based
erupt because right now yeah there's
some private schools but if you had a
hundred percent school choice you're
gonna see like a tenfold increase in
private education and of course it's
going to be mostly values-based because
that's how a parent wants their kids to
be they want their kid in school that
has discipline
and and and uh you know
just a value space they don't want they
don't want their kids in these public
schools they just don't know anything
else
well i'll say this i mean you know you
mentioned uh if you were governor all
i'm saying is i got a really good
feeling that in two years our current
governor is probably gonna be uh
packing some suitcases and i'm probably
uh you know looking at some houses up uh
you know up north maybe for a little
while so i don't know i might have now i
do want to ask you though aren't you
concerned a little bit about how bad the
left has also infiltrated the church in
many ways because that's been happening
all over the country i mean
you have like trans
lesbian methodist like priests that are
having like we're gonna have a drag show
in the church and you're like whoa dude
there was a time there was a time you'd
be afraid that the ground was gonna open
up and swallow you for doing [ __ ] like
this so maybe we don't want to
like and i'm all for
respecting
marginalized communities i'm trying to
do this right yeah maybe you are
look i'm a living let live guy you want
to have your little you know like i
lived in tampa for years it's pretty gay
town there's a lot of stuff going on
cool you got your club you do anything
i'm not against you having your thing
but like like i'm the kind of guy that
thinks people shouldn't be standing and
blocking like uh planned parenthood and
shaming people as they enter it i also
don't think people with blue shaved
heads and like you know girl penises
should be storming into catholic
churches and screaming about abortion
like this yes so i i'm more of like how
about you you do the thing over there
you guys have your thing and then you
guys have your thing however you just
don't bother each other but it seems now
that the church is more
getting
uncomfortably progressive in many ways
yeah well most of the mainline
protestant churches and evangelical
churches and a lot of you know
non-denominational style churches have
been
getting increasingly more woke but as
that happens people are leaving those
churches and they're seeking out actual
conservative real christian churches
and that's the sort of uh
church
that i that i believe in but i also
i also believe that
parents
anything that gets them out of it purely
you know get gets the kids out of a
purely materialistic atheistic
government you know devoid of discipline
of devoid of values devoid of everything
uh education getting them out of that
and put into anything else even if it is
a slightly liberal christian church is
better than the public schools because
the public schools have become
just by the nature of how they operate
uh i think deadening
and uh
in in
and just a weird way procedurally make
more liberal pro-government mentality
students they just do i mean it's just
the way it works
yeah they're built to look exactly like
prisons the food is exactly prison
quality and then you have 12 years of
gambling that your kid's not going to
end up getting molested shot beat up
every week uh like you know what i mean
like there's just too many things now
that you're like i think i want to go to
a place that's like a little catholic
school where they maybe have like you
know 20 people in that grade level you
know what i mean maybe a little better
attention to detail but yeah it's just
that's just my only concern is that some
of the more liberal
like modern churches i just see a lot of
stuff that i'm like this is not what
you're supposed to be doing like
yeah i agree it's there's a lot of that
out there but i think giving the parents
an option is better than what you have
now which is there's no option they just
go to these schools
that
are woke the the teachers are largely
woke they're coming out of the education
colleges they're already pre-disposed to
be
you know liberals and mostly
anti-american style you know various
variations of it but generally
anti-american anti-western style
liberals
and uh that's where the kids go that's
just where they go unless you're wealthy
you can get them out and get them in
another school
um
that's just the way it is so we need to
like actually give parents an
opportunity to get them in a school that
shares their values like conservative
people should be able to without paying
more money send their kid to a very like
pro-christian
pro-america conservative school of
that's he has discipline
and
focus on the great books
and history and civics at no additional
cost i mean that's just very much common
sense to me and we're not doing it we're
not doing it and you know what's anthony
you brought up a really great point
earlier and this actually leads into it
it's like you're right even when
liberals
lose power they if they control the
education system they never lose power
really
you know even if even if the house and
the senate and everybody and a more
governor it doesn't matter if the
factories that are making that are
really producing more of these people
are still functioning like you you you
could you could kill some ants in your
house but if you don't take care of the
ant pile it doesn't really matter and i
think that's the problem i think that's
why they're always so calm um i think
like i said at the end of the day the
the you know debt forgiveness and give
all this money to ukraine and we're
going to hire 87 000 irs agents and
we're going to do everything and
republicans are going to charge like
yeah we're not going to reverse any of
that but hey
slightly lower taxes who wants a tax cut
and you're like okay yes but i would
rather be able to i don't know hey the
stock market's up huh gas prices are
down yeah that's cool yeah uh they still
cut my kid's penis off yeah so i think
we addressed that yeah because i didn't
even get a say like the school didn't
even call me yeah we're getting to that
point too it's good and then you're
gonna be they're gonna take like what
happened in texas when they when they
took that kid away from the father
because the father's like i am not going
to transition the kid and the mom's like
yeah you are and the judge is like then
you're not going to see your kid father
it's your daughter now by the way and
it's like texas
we have a problem now you know
yeah and what do we do and what do we do
so so here's where we go because we're
almost we're coming up towards the end
of the show here but i want to ask this
that's a lot of stuff that obviously big
picture what can people do now day to
day to make it a little bit better what
do you think
the single most
i mean this might sound very
um
stereotypical it sounds very much like a
boilerplate advice but i
really do believe it's the single most
important thing they can do but it's to
get really really really engaged in
these republican primaries
at every level school board state house
state senate
county city commissions especially city
commissions now with the way it's going
with the crime wave you've got to make
sure you get real police departments in
there not woke police chiefs
congress too getting really really
really involved in these republican
primaries
and getting republicans elected who
understand
the extent of power that they already
have and who have a courage and
willingness to use that power to further
the good life and what we consider
the things that we have to do to make
america great again right like that's
that's the most important thing that
they can do
it's not showing up at the school board
meeting and just yelling right it's
actually getting involved
in the primary and helping elect
the right person that's going to
function
as an effective pro-offense strong
america-loving fighter in office and
like getting smart about it and
realizing who the real ones are and who
the grifters are
you know voting on more than just a leaf
letter whatever that is the single most
important thing they can do to save the
country getting really intimately
involved in these republican primaries
and getting smart strong people like
that and recruiting them and maybe being
the person that has to run
i always say i would never have run if i
had a bunch of badass strong freedom
fighting republicans who thought like i
did running i'd just go okay you do that
right i'll go you know go do something
else but they just didn't exist and they
don't exist and so that's why i run and
that's why i'm going to run again for
another position because they're just
we're not going to you should and this i
i know that you tweeted out earlier that
you have a big announcement coming in
spring so i wonder what that's going to
be yeah see we didn't link up in time we
didn't we didn't give you the big rotc
bump yeah right yeah we would have put
you over but put you over the top next
time
i'm going to rule the world
but that's funny because you know we do
talk to a lot of because our show is
obviously everyone listens all over the
planet so yeah
including nikki freed which is why she
didn't come on our show coward
nicki freed on twitter was like yeah
i'll do your show i'm not scared and
then i message her and i'm like okay
would you want to come on the show well
here's my representative then i'm like
okay do you want to come on the show and
then they went radio silent and then we
find out they did this thing it's called
watching our show and then they realized
we're friendly with alex jones was the
reply that we got but meanwhile i'll
give anybody a fair shake like i don't
you know what i mean we'll have you on
we like it's the same way it's casual as
you can see we don't have to agree with
you about everything we've had people on
with disagree of course it's like hey
come on we'll shoot this [ __ ] maybe
it'll come off a little more human to
people and it's like no you guys had
alex jones on once i guess yeah i guess
we're just murderers then yeah so that's
that's where we that that's basically
um you know what
my point was like we tell p a lot of
people it's funny because we're in
florida so we know charlie chris but
it's like i always forget that the rest
of the [ __ ] country doesn't know
charlie chris like we know chris you're
like the flip-flopping guy he is and i'm
like guys you don't understand this is
florida biting you haven't heard this
guy talk yet this guy's insane and ever
and he flip-flops all over the place at
one point he told the priest when he was
a republican i'll get rid of all
abortion in florida and now he's like we
kill every baby here and i'm like man no
middle ground anymore we're just going
full tilt the other way
so i mean i i do think i do think that's
that's uh that's funny i think a lot
more people are paying attention to
florida which is a good thing and a bad
thing uh ever since the ever since the
pandemic but dude absolutely running i'm
telling you man the the one the one
bright hope of everything is if cnn does
a hit piece on you you're saying
something that matters and something
that people care about because if not
they don't do hit pieces on people that
aren't a threat they never do you're
automatically okay in my book if cnn's
going how dare you sir yeah like i'm
like okay this guy's all right then
that's okay yeah
yeah well i enjoyed my four years now so
i enjoyed my two years on the city
commission eustis
and uh you know i enjoy what i'm going
to be doing next but campaigning is half
the battle you got to stay in the battle
right one thing i absolutely hate and i
have zero tolerance for it it just
absolutely
infuriates me is when somebody loses a
race and then they just disappear
they go away and it makes me wonder i'm
like
what would they have been like in office
the the thing that motivated them was
their own perception or like emotional
ties like
i don't know just something about it
is very concerning to me that they would
disappear from the political arena
if they lost their race i feel like they
were motivated by the by the wrong
reasons yeah to get involved to begin
with it's like losing one game and then
saying well i'm never playing football
again it's like so then you never cared
about football you just never cared
about football tom brady's lost super
bowls right like i always say that it's
like and then he won it's like it's okay
and and and i think that's you're right
i do think a lot of people just give up
and go oh well i guess i'm done now
yeah like
i backed probably 10 or 12 candidates
statewide maybe three or four of them
run like at different levels of politics
different offices and i've sufficiently
i think successfully convinced at least
six or seven or eight of them to just
run again next year i'm like take what
you just built and that energy and that
team that fundraising apparatus and your
name id and everything and put it right
back in right back in for either another
office or a rematch or whatever but do
not
walk away this is the worst people in
the world they freaking infuriate me
yeah you just look like that whiny kid
that you're going never going to play
football again and you're like yeah well
you know people get hit get up and you
keep and i really believe that's super i
think that's 100 true i think too many
people just
just back off and and quit i mean look
you know but by the way just again show
you how republicans are different you
know who never quits you know who keeps
running over and over again terrible
liberals that's why they win that's why
biden could run five times and
eventually if you persist long enough
all you have to do is live long enough
and you'll finally be president
something yeah and i wanted to point out
since we're on youtube don't the
election biden really got 81 million
votes yes there's
the integrity of our democratic party
they fortified it with pizza boxes
and it's important you'll get kicked off
if you say anything else so that's what
just happens i think crowder just got
kicked off because uh the arizona uh
center came on the election and i was
like oh they're gonna kick you off now
so i'm afraid of catching a strike every
time i jokingly say we're finding
ballots folks
the algorithm's gonna pick that up yeah
but anthony man thank you so much for
coming on we we really do appreciate it
yeah no this was a lot of fun and um
really like stay in touch with us and
like next time like you know anything we
can do you know we're happy to help help
help out we like to you know love to
help you out the right people i like the
cutter you're just it's our state so it
matters this isn't an empty platitude i
live here so it does matter to us also
also our man anthony here was getting
some love from from rand paul so oh i
saw that street cred right there they
got the street cred yeah the eddie the
eddie bauer sweater best street cred
that matter i love rand paul by the way
it's not eddie bauer it's the um what's
that colombia colombia he likes colombia
i like that uh man thank you so much
anthony uh you can find him at anthony
sabatini on twitter and uh anything else
any other website or people go check out
your stuff
well um yeah sabatini for congress is
still up check it out if you want to see
some of my policy positions
but i'm on every social media platform
at anthony sabatini or vote sabatini
both handles on all major social media
platforms gab getter twitter instagram
facebook linkedin telegram whatever you
use and by the way if you ask anybody
tell them that did you you're cool with
at least one fat cuban guy and one fat
irish guy over here so you see
it's a small world over here
thank you so much man i really
appreciate your time i know it's
valuable so thank you so much for coming
on we do appreciate it this was awesome
thanks guys god bless i'll be back on
again
awesome dude
thank you see ya
all right anthony sabatini uh
might be a little just a little too
based for these people i know around but
we're gonna he's [ __ ] good ideas too
like you can't even say he did it he's
great it's funny man he's you could tell
he's probably a hard guy to write hit
pieces about because he's not like
you know let's be honest there's some
good people in congress you know i don't
mind marjorie taylor green sometimes but
she's also
a you know she can be a [ __ ] clown
you know what i mean she'll just be a
pair of clown shoes for no reason
sometimes but he's got that like he's
calm and cool he's not [ __ ] you know
he's enough like ranting and raving
about you know crazy [ __ ] and that's
what we need so yeah so go yeah go
follow him he's a great follower on
twitter by the way very funny too um